slimy hairy
spooky nobody's got better monsters than
hollywood
and behind every good zombie is a team
of talented artists
discover four stories to show you
another side of the scariest creatures
of the film industry
[Music]
i've been shot on the street stabbed in
prison
been a victim of a slashing twice
actually dead in the morgue
died in a supermarket from
overeating my name is ali murhi
i am a actor and i have played a dead
body
on several occasions the director
usually tells you to hold still
try your best to hold your breath it's
good to slow your breathing down
beforehand
kind of like yoga or meditation
[Music]
played a corpse in the morgue on law and
order
laying down on cold metal while
you know you're practically wearing
nothing is it
it's bone chilling to say the least you
can
take short breaths but they still don't
want to see your chest
going up and down at a distance they're
like wait a second you sure that guy's
dead back there he's
breathing
whenever you end up dying on camera or
playing dead on camera
it brings you to another emotional state
normally people don't think if i was
shot or stabbed what would i do
but once you're there and you're playing
it it's kind of a little traumatic
you feel bad for people when you see
real people get hurt
you take it in a different you know you
see it in a different way
you know my kids watch it sometimes and
they're like dad
you're dead they killed you like no i'm
here with you now i'm okay
[Music]
people ask me this you know from my day
jump isn't what you do tedious
as a stop-motion animator you're very
conscious of
time and of incrementally
moving a three-dimensional object bit by
bit by bit
mad god is a stop-motion film that i've
been kind of making for like the last 30
years
there's nothing stopping me from
continuing doing it
you know forever
[Music]
when i was five years old in 1955 i
saw king kong on television as a stupid
kid i was just enthralled by
hollywood monsters and that was really
the thing that kind of kindled my
appetite subsequently over the years i
have worn many hats
in the motion picture racket i've been
involved with
star wars the robocop series
jurassic park starship troopers on and
on
one of the things that gives me a lot of
pleasure
is is to make something but the day job
has certain requirements to it over the
years those requirements have become
a lot more limiting
the mad god project allowed me to just
make
this more pure thing that was kind of a
form of
therapy for me as an antidote to my day
job
it's a combination of live action and
stop-motion miniature sets in layers
like a collage
for lack of a better term it's a passion
project
and things keep getting deeper and
darker and
hotter there are imaginary cities that
are
built out of iron ingots there's like
strange jungles that you go through
there's this
huge dystopic post-industrial
nightmare city and it just goes on and
on and on
exactly anything that i can think of
inherent in it there's a
level of surprise that i i think you
know for me is very childlike kind of a
thing
i shoot here at my studio in berkeley
it's stocked with all kinds of stuff
for all kinds of different electronic
projects woodworking projects
lights cameras so it's a huge toy box
all of the characters in that god are
built by me
the process begins with the articulated
skeleton and that's made by ball and
socket or hinge joints
that allow you to move the characters
incrementally one frame at a time
and then i just wrap lengths of
polyurethane foam
and build up the general mass
from there i will take latex skins
adhere them
with rubber cement paint the thing and
it's ready to shoot
when you're actually shooting a
stop-motion scene
you project into the character
and sometimes it can get very
complicated you
are always gauging acceleration and
deceleration
weight and mass and then that kind of
leads
to but you know what what would make it
better
for me this whole process is more of a
compulsion
i really have no say over it's just
something that i
i have to do you know i've been doing it
so long it's
i i breathe i live and breathe in this
world it's
all i think about
when it comes to horror movies there's
an actor who is so
good at his job his performances stay
with you like a nightmare he just can't
wake up from
but trust us he's a really nice guy
could you give us a club let's go i'm
javier boutet and i'm an actor
and javier's been in a lot of movies you
probably just didn't see him because
well
he looks quite different most of the
time i feel very comfortable
in monster roles i've been in
it mama country in two greens some peak
slender man and let's not forget he's
been in the mummy and alien too
i'm very skinny i'm 2 meters tall and
56 kilograms
it's not a problem of eating because i
love to eat it's a
personal condition is call it a marfan
syndrome
javier's career started when he met a
prosthetic makeup teacher
in madrid this led to javier's first
monster role
in the movie beneath still waters that
was my first makeup my first
work in a real movie and well after that
all the makeup artists start seeing my
work and
start proposing me in other roles last
year i've been
working in eight or nine different
shows there's gotta be some behind the
scenes gossip then
yeah well i i was in queensland peak i
was
out of all the makeup and i was the last
day with guillermo del toro
and i say tom hiddleston and i said okay
see you was a pleasure and he said who
are you
so i say i i was your ex-wives
okay okay sorry i didn't recognize you
but don't pigeonhole this guy he might
be a monster most of the time
but he's got dramatic range okay guys
you ready
really love what you do because it's
going to be hard and long
journey be prepared you never know
what's going to happen
don't be shy don't let the fear paralyze
you
so relax
you know what i mean
if i can ask for something i loved
i would love to be a big sith
i will rule the galaxy
was our first feature a point break did
we do that before
drummers not officially yeah right so as
a company
tremors would be the first technically
the first feature i guess
i don't know someone should google that
[Music]
i would like to introduce you to tom
woodruff jr who is the co-founder of
amalgamated dynamics i'd like to
introduce you to alec gillis he's the
co-founder of adi
home of the oscar-winning creature
effects team
when people think of practical effects
creatures you think of non-computer
generated
characters we've been lucky to be
involved with some of the biggest and
best
of those types of monsters we did the
worms and tremors
we did the fat makeups on tim allen in
the santa claus all the practical
animals in jumanji
we've done the alien we've done the
predator starship troopers
i wasn't done you can keep going buddy
and of course there's always
the gorilla cut right now that's perfect
right there
now we cut putting the gorilla costume
[Music]
we started performing our own creatures
because we both had this sort of uh
observation of stuntmen despite their
talents and their skills
them going into a creature suit and not
really knowing how to make a creature
suit work
it would be very weird for us to just
say we're going to build something and
then bring it to set and say now what
are you hungry you want some food are
you hungry
if you're a digital animator you build
the character and you follow through and
you make it move and you bring it to
life so that's our philosophy is the
final step is
performance because that's where it
lives you want to try a little tiny
piece
here go ahead go ahead
what do you think you want some more you
hey hey he's
listen listen i can get you fresh bread
i can i can get you fresh bread
tremors is an example of a film that was
from the pre-digital era
and if you look at it the practical
effects they've stood the test of time
and we're proud of that
digital effects can do things that we
can't possibly do practical effects have
a presence to them that even the best
cgi work gets close to but doesn't
completely achieve
in other words there's more emotion i
believe to a practical creature than to
a digital creature
wave to the camera and say goodbye
bye bye
[Music]
he's so temperamental hey everybody my
name is drew bibi
and i'm here in my terrible home studio
that i've made during quarantine
and i wanted to tell you about our new
podcast called great big story
it's got more surprising and delightful
stories just like this one
so head over to apple podcast to spotify
wherever you get your favorite podcasts
and download
great big story